have you heard of the show the wheel of
fortune remember the wheel of fortune of
the game showing ways it was a gentleman
by the name of Chuck Woolery never heard
of Chuck he's also uh he was a game show
host he was pretty well known he tweeted
something and I want to know how would
you if we can get this message to him
this gets to him how would you respond
to this was his 2 l's very shot it's one
thing when you hear you know
Islamophobia is a big machine it's like
200 plus a million-dollar annually
people are spending to you know the
basis lawmen and many of those
information lies and I think he our
brother humanity I caught up into this
he says and I want to know how would you
respond to it on shorty he says if you
don't know us is Chuck Woolery if you
don't know Islam is evil then you don't
know history and you refuse to reason
I'm not saying that every Muslim is evil
different different would you respond to
him if you had a chance to sit with them
to talk with him or maybe we can get
this message to him what would you say
to him the basic message to him and two
other friends us as well don't next
Islam as an authentic teaching of
actions of some muscle
tell me of one thinking were religion
where's throughout history they never
committed as individual or collectively
some of the worst kind of atrocities if
i were to understand the Christianity
for example and the novel teaching of
Christ peace be upon him and the light
of the crusade or the Inquisition or
Vietnam War or world wars and Otto I'll
get totally or apartheid in South Africa
and the name of religion I'd say will be
mistaken because you're taking bad
examples even a not even a habit that
example of people who deviated from
those noble teaching and call that
Christian has the same thing applies to
Judaism somewhat notorious and there's
treatment raises and particularly
noxious as a religion science of
Zionists are not particularly deleting
the Palestinian taking their land away
and building certain on it Buddhism
beautiful religion had some good points
yet look at how some goodness in men
mark are burning Muslims and the
religious and killing them by it listen
I should say that who the Sultan to this
intuition and the right and burning
alive emotional so during some of those
right and some religious leaders even
insight and apple of that like most
excited that you say
morality don't mix the teaching what's
all very good and a voice also
selectivity if you look at the Muslim
history 14th century it there was only
minor issues that were sent in fighting
in fact but it was a civilization that
contributed immensely and actually
prompted the European Renaissance it's a
culture art architecture so I don't try
to reduce everything on it the negative
part 2 which we admit yes most unlike
any other committed wrong with the
question in the different sometimes only
a degree to be fair and if you point
fingers to work others you know that
many other fingers pointing to you if
you fair and honorable in terms of
making complaint so let's not get into
this calamity wrong do you understand
that Islam that you can't even
did you understand it from its authentic
sources not through polemical writings
are slim phobic material I'd be very
glad to meet with you and sit down
quietly and peacefully and respectfully
and explain to you slam giving from the
its original authentic sources lie and
tell me what is wrong and alliance I too
after that help you are seriously
beautiful beautiful we pray that this
message gets to you and all of humanity
we're here at the Dean show trying to
clear up those misconceptions trying to
deliver this truth to you and if you
have any other questions call us take
the higher route main calling it doesn't
it didn't it is solve any problems but
making the human connection talking like
civilized human beings that's how we can
develop a better understanding call us a
1-800 662 Islamic we have any question
and we hope to see you here every week
at the DS show subscribe if you haven't
already until next time peace be with
you
[Applause]